what is the true nature of the universe
to answer this question humans come up
with stories to describe the world we
test our stories and learn what to keep
and what to throw away but the more we
learn the more complicated and weird our
stories become some of them so much so
but it's really hard to know what
they're actually about like string
theory a famous controversial and often
misunderstood story about the nature of
everything why did we come up with it
and is it correct or just an idea we
should check out to understand the true
nature of reality we looked at things up
close and were amazed wondrous
landscapes in the dust zoos of bizarre
creatures complex protein robots all of
them made from structures of molecules
made up of countless even smaller things
atoms we thought they were the final
layer of reality until we smash them
together really hard and discovered
things that can't be divided any more
elementary particles but now we had a
problem they're so small that we could
no longer look at them think about it
what is seeing to see something we need
light an electromagnetic wave this wave
hits the surface of the thing and gets
reflected back from it into your eye the
wave carries information from the object
that your brain uses to create an image
so you can't see something without
somehow interacting with it seeing is
touching an active process not a passive
one this is not a problem with most
things but particles are very very very
small so small that the electromagnetic
waves we use to see aren't too big to
touch them visible light just passes
over them we can try to solve this by
creating electromagnetic waves with more
and much smaller wave
but more wavelengths means more energy
so when we touch a particle with a wave
that has a lot of energy it alters it by
looking at a particle we change it so we
can't measure elementary particles
precisely this fact is so important that
it has a name the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle the basis of all quantum
physics so what does a particle look
like then what is its nature we don't
know if we look really hard we can see a
blurry sphere of influence but not the
particles themselves
we just know they exist but if that's
the case how can we do any science with
them we did what humans do and invented
a new story a mathematical fiction the
story of the point particle we decided
that we would pretend that a particle is
a point in space any electron is a point
with a certain electric charge and a
certain mass all indistinguishable from
each other this way physicists could
define them and calculate all of their
interactions this is called quantum
field theory and solved a lot of
problems all of the standard model of
particle physics is built on it and it
predicts lots of things very well some
quantum properties of the electron for
example have been tested and are
accurate up to zero point zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero two percent so while particles are
not really pointed by treating them as
if they were we get a pretty good
picture of the universe not only that
this idea advanced science it also led
to a lot of real-world technology we use
every day but there's a huge problem
gravity in quantum mechanics all
physical forces are carried by certain
particles but according to Einstein's
general relativity gravity is not a
force like the others in the universe
if the universe is a play particles are
the actors but gravity is the stage to
put it simply gravity is a theory of
geometry the geometry of space-time
itself of distances which we need to
describe with absolute precision but
since there is no way to precisely
measure things in the quantum world our
story of gravity doesn't work with our
story of quantum physics when physicists
tried to add gravity to the story by
inventing a new particle their
mathematics broke down and this is a big
problem if we could marry gravity to
quantum physics and the standard model
we would have the theory of everything
so very smart people came up with a new
story they asked what is more complex
than a point a line or a string string
theory was born
what makes string theory so elegant is
that it describes many different
elementary particles as different modes
of vibration of the string just like a
violin string vibrating differently can
give you a lot of different notes a
string can give you different particles
most importantly this includes gravity
string theory promise to unify all
fundamental forces of the universe this
caused enormous excitement and hype
string theory quickly graduated to a
possible theory of everything
unfortunately string theory comes with a
lot of strings attached
much of the maths involving a consistent
string theory does not work in our
universe with its three spatial and one
temporal dimensions string theory
requires ten dimensions to work out so
string theorists dip calculations in
model universes and then try to get rid
of the six additional dimensions and
describe our own universe but so far
nobody has succeeded and no prediction
of string theory has been proven in an
experiment so string theory did not
reveal the nature of our universe
one could argue that in this case string
theory ready isn't useful at all science
is all about experiments and predictions
if we can't do those why should we
bother with strings it really is all
about how we use it physics is based on
maths
two plus two makes four this is true no
matter how you feel about it and the
maths in string theory does work out
that's why string theory is still useful
imagine that you want to build a cruise
ship but you only have blueprints for a
small rowing boat there are plenty of
differences the engine the materials the
scale but both things are fundamentally
the same things that float so by
studying the rowing boat blueprints you
might still learn something about how to
build a cruise ship eventually with
string theory we can try to answer some
questions about quantum gravity that
have been puzzling physicists for
decades such as how black holes work or
the information paradox string theory
may point us in the right direction when
used in this spirit string theory
becomes a precious tool for theoretical
physicists and help them discover new
aspects of the quantum world and some
beautiful mathematics so maybe the story
of string theory is not the theory of
everything but just like the story of
the point particle it may be an
extremely useful story we don't yet know
what the true nature of reality is but
we'll keep coming up with stories to try
and find out until one day hopefully we
do know this video was supported by the
Swiss National Science Foundation and
realized with the scientific advice of
Alessandro Swan dreaming
[Music]